your leading mit's effort to design a
spark a compact High field DT burning
takamak
how does it work what is it what's the
motivation uh what's the design what are
the ideas behind it yeah at its heart
it's exactly the same concept as eater
so it's basically a configuration of
electromagnets it's arranged in the
shape of a donut and within that we will
do we would do the same thing that
happens in all the other token Max and
including an eater and in this one is it
namely you put in gas make it into a
plasma you heat it up it gets about 100
million degrees
the differentiator in spark is that we
use the actual deuterium tritium Fuel
and because of the access to very high
magnetic fields it's in a very compact
space it's very very small
what I mean by small so it's 40 times
smaller in volume than either but it
uses exactly the same physical
principles so this comes from the high
magnetic field so in the end like what
is why does this matter what it does is
it does those things and it should get
to the point where it's producing over
100 million watts of fusion power
but remember it's 40 times smaller so
either was 500 megawatts technically our
our design is around 150 megawatts so
it's only about a factor of three
difference despite being 40 times
smaller
um and we see
um QP large
order of 10 or something like this at
that at that at that state is very
important scientifically because this is
basically matches what eater is looking
to do the plasma is dominated by its own
heating that's very very important and
it does that for about 10 seconds
and the reason it's for 10 seconds is
that in terms of that that basically
allows everything to settle in terms of
the fusion in the plasma equilibrium
everything is nice and settled so you
know you have seen the physical state at
which you would expect a power plant to
operate basically for for magnetic
Fusion like wow right
but it's more than that and it's more
than that it's because about who's
building it and why and how it's being
financed
um so that scientific pathway was made
possible by the fact that we had access
to a next generation of magnet
technology so to explain this real quick
why do we call it you you said it in the
words a superconducting magnet what does
this mean
superconducting magnet means that the
materials which are in the electromagnet
have no electrical resistance therefore
when the electric current is put into it
the current goes around unimpeded so it
could basically keep going around and
around you know technically for infinity
and what that means are for eternity and
what that means is that the um when you
energize these large electromagnets
they're they're using basically zero
electrical power to maintain them
whereas if you would do this in a normal
wire like copper you basically make an
enormous toaster oven that's consuming
enormous amounts of power and getting
hot which is the problem that was the
technical breakthrough that was realized
by myself and at the time my students
and postdocs and colleagues at MIT was
that we we saw the Advent of this new
this new superconducting material which
would allow us to access much higher
magnetic fields is basically the next
generation of the technology and
um and it was quite disruptive to Fusion
that namely what it would allow that if
we could if we could get to this point
where we can make the round 20 Tesla We
Knew by the rules of tokamax that this
is going to be is going to allow us to
vastly shrink like the sizes of these
devices so it wouldn't take
um although although it's a worthy goal
it wouldn't take a seven nation
International you know treaty basically
to build it you could build it with a
company and a university it's the same
kind of design but now using the
superconducting magnets yeah and if in
fact if you look at it's like it's if
you just expand the size of it they're
like they look almost identical to each
other because it's based on the and
actually that comes for a Reason by the
way is that it also looks like a bigger
version of the Toca Mac that we ran at
MIT for 20 years where we established
the scientific benefits in fact of these
higher magnetic fields so that's the
pathway that runs so always say so what
does this mean the context is different
because
it was made because it's primarily being
made by a a private sector company spun
out of MIT because the way that it
raised money and the purpose of the
entity which is there is to make
commercial fusion power plants not just
to make a scientific experiment this is
actually why we have
um
that's why we have a partnership right
is that our purpose at MIT is not to
commercialize directly but boy do we
want to advance the technology and the
science that comes along this and that's
the reason we're sort of doing it
together so it's MIT and Commonwealth
Fusion systems so what's what's
interesting to say about financing and
this seems like from a scientific
perspective maybe not an interesting
topic but it's perhaps an extremely
interesting topic I mean you can just
look at the testing between uh SpaceX
and NASA for example yes it's just clear
that there's different financing
mechanisms can actually significantly
accelerate
the development of Science and
Engineering
it's great that you brought that up we
use several historic analogs and one of
them is around SpaceX which is an
appropriate one because space you know
putting things into orbit has a just a
has a minimum size to it and integrated
technological complexity and budget and
things like this so you know our point
when we were like talking about starting
like a fusion commercialization you know
company people look at you like like
isn't this still really just a science
experiment you know but are one of the
things that we pointed to was SpaceX to
say well tell me like 25 years ago how
many people would have voted that you
know the the leading entity on the
planet to put things into orbit it's a
private company people would have
thought you were not so right it's like
and what is interesting about SpaceX was
that it proved it's more than actually
just financing
it's really the purpose of the
organization so the purpose of a gun and
I'm not against Public Finance or
anything like that but the purpose of a
public entity like in like NASA
correctly you know speaks to the
political
because because the cost comes from the
political you know uh assembly that is
there and and I guess from us eventually
as well too but its purpose wasn't about
like making a commercial product it's
about fundamental Discovery and so forth
which is all which is all really great
it's like why did why did SpaceX it's
interesting because why did SpaceX
succeed so well is because the idea was
it's like the the focus that comes in
the idea that you're going to
relentlessly like reduce cost and
increase efficiency is a drive that
comes from the commercial aspect of it
right and this also then changes
um the people in the teams which are
doing it as well too and in fact
trickles throughout the whole thing
because the purpose isn't while you're
while you're advancing things like it's
really good that we can put things in
orbit a lot less more cheaply like in
advance of science which is an
interesting Synergy right and it's the
same thing that that we think is going
to happen in fuse that namely these this
is a bootstrap effect that actually that
when you start to push yourself to think
about near-term commercialization it
like allows the size to get in hand
faster which then allows the
commercialization to go faster into an
up we go by the way we've seen this also
in another like again it's a you have to
watch out with with analogies because
they only can go so far but like biotech
is another one like you look at the
Human Genome Project which was
it's sort of like it's it to me that's
like like mapping the human genome is
like like that we can make net energy
from Fusion like it's one of those like
in your drawer that you go this is a
significant achievement by Humanity
right in the century and there's the
Human Genome Project fully government
funded it's going to take 20 25 years
because we basically know the technology
we're just going to be really diligent
keep going and then all of a sudden what
comes along disruptive technology right
you can sequence you you know shotgun
sequencing and computer you know
recognition patterns and basically oh I
can do this a hundred times faster
they're like wow right yeah so so that's
really the uh you know to me that the
story about why we started why we
launched Commonwealth Fusion systems was
more than just about another source of
funding which it is a different source
of fun because it comes it's also a
different purpose which is very
important but there's also something
about a mechanism that creates culture
so giving power to like a young student
ambitious student to have a tremendous
impact on the progress of nuclear fusion
creates a culture that actually makes
progress more aggressively like like
you've said when Seven Nations
collaborate it gives more incentive to
the bureaucracy to slow things down to
kind of have let's have first have a
discussion and certainly don't give
voice to the young ambitious Minds that
are really pushing stuff forward yeah
and there's something about like the
private sector that
rewards encourages inspires young minds
to say in the most beautiful ways Fu to
the
it is just for the boss yeah just sort
of like we'll make it faster we'll make
it simpler we'll make it better we'll
make it cheaper yeah and sometimes that
brashness doesn't bear out you know
that's an aspect that you just take a
different risk profile as well too but
you're right it's this you know of them
I mean it was interesting our our own
trajectory at the at the fusion Center
was like we were pushed into this place
by necessity as well too because I told
you we have and we had operated for a
long time a Tokamak at uh on the MIT
campus achieve these World Records like
100 million degree plasma and so I was
like wow this is fantastic but
you know somewhat ironically I have to
say is that it was like oh but we're not
this isn't the future of fusion anymore
like we're not we're just gonna stop
with small projects because it's too
small right so we should need we need to
really move on to these much bigger
projects because that's really the
future of fusion and so it was defunded
um and this basically put at risk like
like we were going to essentially lose
MIT in the ecosystem really a fusion
both from the research but also clearly
important from the educational part of
it so we you know we push back against
this we got a Lifeline we were able to
go it was in this it was in this time
scale that we basically came up with
this idea it's like we should do this
and in the end it was all of those the
the people who were in the sea level of
the company were all literally students
who got caught in that they were PhD
students at the time so you talk about
enabling another generation it's like
yeah there you go right so spark gave a
lifeline
but it's way more than that it was it
wasn't just about like surviving for the
sake of surviving it was like in the end
for me it became like this I remember
the moment when you talk about these
moments as a scientist and we were just
like we were working so hard about
figuring out like does this really would
this really work like in this it's
complex like does the magnet work does
the interaction with the plasma work
does all these things work and it was
just the grind push push push push and I
remember the moment because I was
sitting
in my office in Brookline and and and
and there was just like I read like and
I was in I don't know whatever the 20 or
40th slide or something into it and it
was sort of that moment like it just
came together and I like I I got I
couldn't even sit down because all I was
just like my wife was like why are you
walking around the apartment like this
like I just couldn't she I said it's
going to work like it's going to work
like holy that moment of realization is
like kind of amazing but it also brings
the responsibility of making it work as
well so you mean like that magic
realization that you could have this uh
this modern uh Magnum technology and you
can actually like why do we need to work
with either we can do it here yeah yeah
but it's interesting that either is
um that one one of one of the reasons
that like that we started with a group
of six of us at MIT and then once we got
some funding through the through the
establishment of the company it became a
slightly larger but in the end we had a
rather small team like this was like a
team of order of like 20 to 25 people
design spark in like a like about two
years right how does that happen well
we're clever but you have to give eater
it's due here as well too that again
this is an aspect always of the
bootstrap up like I go back to the Human
Genome Project so modern day genomics
would not be possible without the
underlying basis that came from setting
that up it had to be there it had to be
curiosity driven public program is the
same with either but we because we had
the tools that were there to understand
either we also have the tools to
understand spark so we we parlayed those
in an extremely powerful way to be able
to tell us about what was going to
happen so these things are never simple
right it's like people look at this go
oh this means we should like should we
really have a public based program about
Fusion or should we have it all in the
private it's like no no the answer is
neither way because in all these complex
Technologies you have to keep pushing on
all the fronts to actually get it there